so this is an extraordinary group of
animated shorts I mean a really a
amazing year just beautiful emotional
work so original so original so we'll
take a few minutes and go through each
film and and I just excited to hear what
you guys have to say
well Daria with daughter this was such
an emotional piece and it seemed really
personal it's one I truly related to
having a dad who was uncomfortable with
daughters you know your your use of such
rapid motion gave this stop-motion film
such an immediacy it was just really
stunning I'm just curious
you know how you achieve that and what
brought about that sort of decision this
decision came to me when I wrote the
script and when I wrote it I was
thinking that it is going to be drama
and also as I really like to to watch
live-action movies and I was thinking
what drama means for me and the answer
came to me that it is films by lars von
trier lars von trier by Dogma by
Vinterberg or by Darden Brothers so I
was thinking what the aesthetic they use
for this film for their films and I
started to think about handheld camera
movement about this documentary style so
I decided that it could work for my
story really good and I was very
inspired by this idea to make handheld
camera movement in my stop-motion film
but after I really didn't know how I'm
going to make it but yeah it was quite
tricky to find the way actually it will
it is my student film and we did
have budget we didn't have kind of
motion control all this stuff so I had
to find the way how to make it using a
really simple camera tracker and camera
mount so I made some tests and I found
the way how to make this camera movement
manually and actually I moved the camera
frame by frame using actually references
as a reference films by lars von trier
and yeah and after I just understood and
made it more intuitively this camera
movement and maybe consciously I deleted
it camera to make it more documentary
and yeah it was like yeah wonderful and
the it's funny that the delicate moves
of having the camera off the shoulder
just catching a bit of the I could still
convey so much so much a really
beautiful story of a father and a
daughter you you have a background as a
sound designer and the soundscape on
this was was exquisite as well can you
talk a little bit about that yeah I
studied as a sound designer I played the
piano before and mmm actually when I
write the script I also hear this film
I'm gonna animate the film my eye I
heard this and when we were thinking
about collaboration with sound designer
I was thinking why should I explain
someone how would this go how I want to
do to have it if I have it in my head so
it was easier to make kind of rough
sound mix by myself so I made it by
myself and my classmate helped me to
make it more like seen cinema mix to
make the final mix so yeah and actually
I I didn't use kind of Foley records I
went to the street with record or I went
to the train station or I recorded
record that sounds in my kitchen so it
was also
the commentary and I really wanted to
make it Georgie to make it more
documentary filling and it was funny
when I made this rough mix it was dirty
and when my classmate asked me sometimes
oh you know maybe I should use denoiser
because it is kind of dirty and I told
no no no I really liked it please really
keep this this noisy center there every
stuff and so it was kind of intention to
make yeah yes so much storytelling was
just told with the with the sound yeah
really really a wonderful achievement
really amazing
[Applause]
Matthew would Karen with hair love this
this movie is really getting a lot of
attention a lot of well-deserved praise
it's it's so funny it's so charming and
it's ultimately really heartwarming can
you talk a little bit about the subject
matter of hair vlogging and why I mean
so many we all connect to it somehow
I've never heard of hair vlogging before
but I'm old so yeah you know the natural
hair vlogging and you know in the black
community it's a kind of a big thing you
know when the advent of YouTube it just
kind of made it a lot easier to you know
if you have different styles you want to
try it's kind of a whole movement online
and you know a couple years ago in 2017
I come across all these viral videos of
black fathers that we're doing their
daughter's hair and it just felt so cute
and charming but was also this weird
thing because you know I think people
often times give dads extra credit for
doing just normal stuff their parents
should do and and uh and you know mom
does it just kind of whatever but if a
dad is like oh my God he's so cute and
amazing and you know and it just it felt
like a good opportunity to just to try
to normalize that you know I know I have
a lot a father myself
but um you know it was kind of a love
letter to my future daughter and also
just I'll have a lot of friends that are
young young fathers and you know just
really wanted to do something that
really showed them in a positive light
you know so often in mainstream media
black men and black fathers get such a
bad rap and you they're rarely seen and
also to really represent a black family
in animation in 2017
you know spider-verse hadn't come out
yet and I think in the only movies I
remember seeing a black family in
animation we're like babies kids persist
in the Frog and home and it just felt
like a really good opportunity to
showcase characters that you know young
kids could see themselves in you know
meaning it was really powerful when you
don't see yourself and don't see
characters that look like you and have
hair that looks like you and the same
type of nose and complexion you know can
really make you wonder if you're less
than and so this was just kind of
something we try to do for you know
people out there that don't normally see
themselves represented Karen well I know
that Bruce was involved in this
co-directed with you and Peter Ramsey of
Sony can you can Karen can you tell us
how Sony got involved with Matthew on
this movie and Matthew sort of a joy
because he came did the Kickstarter
raised all the money you know and then
had a following of like an audience
online that was like rooting for him and
you saw the credits at the end like yes
there were like 1500 or so Kickstarter's
that were part of it so he was a dream
come true in terms of filmmakers already
kind of having their built in money and
marketing but but so we brought on you
know to kind of really build because
Matthew never done animation before and
sort of kudos to both well Bruce Smith
and never downing who are co directors
with that Bruce is here too and and and
Stacy Newton one of my producing
partners who came from Pixar was sort of
really understanding when we kind of
brought the high bar how we were gonna
really make this just you know beautiful
and really kind of put it all together
so yeah so I was doing it sort of as a
producer on the side because I had my
day job was an executive at Sony and I'm
my house I'd hustle was trying to
produce this movie and
so we were doing it and you know again
kudos to Sony Pictures for just sort of
letting us do that and then they sort of
got wind of like what we were doing and
we're really proud of it you know and so
it's just really grateful that they you
not only kind of gave us a little bit of
money gave us some resources to finish
it but also gave us the opportunity to
put it in front of Angry Birds so that
it could qualify and you know it was
just amazing cuz I think you know
spider-verse was sort of the first you
know four way and to sort of just
showing diverse storytelling and they I
think they really understood what this
meant and again it's not easy it's not
hard when he does all the financing on
his own but thank you to the Kickstarter
backer your stuff is in the mail but no
it was it was a dream come true in terms
of just them you know being able to
partner with this yeah and and now it's
a best-selling book it's on the New York
Times best selling like top five books
yeah he's a great congratulations that's
great
awesome so Rosanna and Kathryn of kit
ball this movie really spoke to me I'm
an animal lover I'd loved it
I stay up late watching animal videos
just to calm down as well and spirit I
could really see that in there too all
the details of the little kitten I mean
we've all seen that when they flip
anyway it's really wonderful but I know
it was inspired by that but then it it
the where you took it was a very
poignant and and darker direction
ultimately you know very heartwarming
can you talk a little bit about how why
and how you made that transition yeah so
just for full transparency it did start
as extreme indulgence and my love for
cat videos and animal videos but but
also you know I originally had sought
out to become a study to become a
veterinarian so that that passion for
animal behavior and observing that has
always been there with me and so as I
worked at it on it over the years and
eventually a scat hendrickson to be my
producer when it was still completely
independent on the side while we also
had our day jobs not easy but but we
still were burning the midnight oil with
that
eventually when I showed it to my peers
at Pixar you know their their fellow
storytellers and they all have extremely
high standards and all of them you know
each of us always trying to find the
truth to the the work we do one of them
asked me what is it that's so personal
about this why are you telling this
story because as fun as these cat
shenanigans are like where is the story
and you know and I really looked at it I
realized okay it was it was something
there was something there about empathy
there was something there about
connection that even from the very
beginning I had always been exploring
but when I really looked at what I could
pour into it for myself you know there's
there's this struggle I've always had
just you know is social anxiety and
shyness and this feeling of disconnect
and isolation but wanting to find
connection wanting to truly connect with
other people but not knowing how that's
that's what I realized was the heart of
the story
and you know working once again like I
said studying to become a veterinarian
you know you hear about the stories of a
lot of animals especially in shelters
and and that's when I learned more about
pit bulls and when I learned about as
well as black cats and how oftentimes
say that it's really hard for them to be
adopted and so I just wanted to kind of
explore a lot of those themes and this
really smart a really short short and
with the help of our awesome editor
who's here in audience at Katie Shafer
Bishop she was able to help help wrangle
an 18-minute short into a nine minute
short so thank you Katie and thank you
Kat for bringing back to life yeah
Katherine so this this movie the short
is 2d from Pixar yes right yeah they're
not known for that and and I understand
that you also created kind of a unique
pipeline to make this we did and that
was one of the most exciting parts of
this project for me and you know Rosie
you could speak to why you wanted to
pursue 2d from a storytelling point of
view but once I knew that that was what
Rosie wanted to do
we were able to go to the executive team
explain our reasoning and they said
that's great you have six months and
here's your budget let's see what you
can do and so with that in mind it
became really important to us to
leverage as much of Pixar's pipeline and
technology that was already in place and
so one thing that we did that was hugely
beneficial for us was we had our art
team quickly mock up our set in the in a
3d model we dropped a camera in there
like we would do a layout Scout for any
one of our features Rosie was able to
scout the set figure out the best shots
for storytelling purposes and that was
kind of our rough draft that we were
able to pass off to our background
painters and our 2d animators so both of
those departments could work in tandem
and then we were able to bring it all
together in compositing and it ended up
coming out beautifully so good job Rosie
thank you and yeah and just to the 2d
nature of it it's yes Pixar is was known
for revolutionising like the CG
animation and some might argue killing
2d in some ways but I don't think so but
still you could see the the CG go up and
the 2d start to become less present and
mainstream market and we weren't the
first to start experimenting with 2d
Teddy Newton was the first what day and
night at Pixar and then your friend the
rat as well and then for me I wanted to
do 2d because it was my first love it's
you know growing up as we all did
watching Disney features Japanese
animation European animation is such
beauty in in purity and the hand-drawn
animation and also I felt that the
kitten could not have been animated any
other way than 2d because just like
every drawing is unpredictable and not
the same the kitten is also
unpredictable
so yeah that's true so cute it makes my
teeth hurt thank you yeah this return to
TV this could be the year that we see a
2d animated feature when an Oscar it's
quite possible so
memorabilia from France I know
jean-francois you're gonna be
translating yes thank you you're welcome
my dear
this film was so moving and devastating
and such an homage to art to painting
from the impressionistic from the van
Gogh even to the paint just dissolving
at the end with with his with his memory
can you talk a little bit about how that
style why that that worked for you for
this film what was the inspiration
if accumulated know the person Katie -
she have a concluded her the truth satin
veil was a so Dijon he Polly do the
melody even Placido at that damn Aladdin
Bruna wanted to to write and to direct a
film about Alzheimer but he wanted to to
put the audience inside the head of a
person with suffering of Alzheimer a
auto constantly pre-medical down which
was a part the copy facility implicit or
a pool you malleable is great you cheat
from an article in France and for him he
believed that it will be easier to to
create this character of painter of
artists to try to put himself in this
hell opportunity concept predicted
malady sukoon emoji yep are really
useful to the present and when you have
this kind of diseases he'll Ness you
don't remember what you had one hour ago
but you can remember old
souvenirs I collaborated over mantras
important to see Rosa
some order to seize art is killing me
all mortal as your faith in if you know
how to set V Torah studies power and
when the helix became become harder all
your souvenirs especially or the painter
or the heart is you loved come back came
back to the memory to the last memory of
the painter if Aristotle said when power
feel destroyed Allah but it didn't want
to write a film that could be a kind of
Treaty of history of heart who respect
the diversity of album and not survey to
see the latest and respect the audience
will spend more time to discover who was
the hottest he thought it talked about
more than the story the print isn't
artists the pigeon etymology it took ten
references and mixed all the references
doctor local voila voila you can have
some of some kind of heavy dances but
there is more specific detail that it's
more difficult to discover the reference
I want to see a voter has to snap a few
solar Seraphim SoLoMo but for Bree no
it's before love story more than a film
about art yeah that's very clear it's a
beautiful love story and heartbreaking
and what one that frightens the hell out
of a lot of us creeping up towards our
Jubilee birth
beautiful work really thank you thank
you
[Applause]
so sister from from Shiki she really a
delicate balance here you you you you
lure us in with the story of a brother
and a sister having a typical you know
sibling relationship and then you pull
the rug out from under us you know you
you actually are the second child though
yes yes yeah
luckily yeah well I know I was Brian
Reese in China during the 90s and then
definitely like as a second child during
that time was like really really
experienced and then with my friend's
life and out I have a brother they
always ask me what does it feel like to
grow up with a sibling because most of
them didn't have a chance to grow up
with sibling so I always like to the
story oh man me and my brother leg to
them to tell them you know you know
they're you know and then so like
eventually I want to make a film about
about like siblings just to show them
you know what does feel like to grow up
with a sibling and then when I started
to develop the script and I know like
for me personally I know you know the
stories of siblings that like basically
the first half of the movie was based on
my experience of growing up with my
brother
I actually interview him a lot about his
feelings that's why the little sister in
the team is so annoying
did you guys really do a tooth tree yeah
yeah I mean that's always in my
imagination like you know Puma because
action I actually play lead bill working
here I I know like and a lot of people
knows Chinese but the Chinese character
of T's is sounds exactly the same as
sprout that's where that confusion come
from because it's just you know in
Chinese character the teeth on top of
the teeth this is us grass you put a
little bit grass on the top it becomes
sprout
that's why you know is like lots of
Chinese children with lemon is taking it
as peace is gonna go up on the tree okay
why felt i mean it's lovely it's soft
but wow i just looks crazy to work with
ya lt's yeah it's really interesting
material to to work with install motion
I think originally like wedges started
to make this film
I wasn't sure like what the style is
gonna be like you know the visuals and
materials because you know animation has
so many possibilities like you can't
have to explore through the making of
the film and the idea like at the
beginning I did try like 2d I tried show
like illustrations and I did like you
some clay to make the purpose - and then
in the end I just like going back just
think back you know my childhood because
the film is mostly about childhood and
the idea lots of like Chinese ink
pending once I kill my friend you know
my mouse and me to study that while I
was a kid and then so the color palette
of the Chinese ink pending the black and
white and the register become you know
my memory of childhood and I want to
create the imagery that looks similar
with that and then also like in the
story - that that boy was actually
enjoying ink painting so I put that joy
in front of every small stories so so I
just like look for materials and I found
out who is really great material that I
can you know help create this like
greeting color or black and white and
then you know just like I just feel I
really felt the same of the film and
then it looks really warm and you know
fluffy you know just like really some
memory I want to create so yeah I guess
it worked out pretty good yes it did
well I want to thank you all very much
for being here
[Applause]